- [Sal] Steve, what are doing here?
- [Steve] Hey, Sal.
We're gonna look at this
question of, why do empires fall?
- [Sal] And for those of you
who don't know Steve Schraeder,
he is a World History
Fellow here at Khan Academy
and also a former World History teacher.
- [Steve] So what we want to
do here is use this big ideas,
these big factors that are
somewhat common across empires,
to sort of understand how
specific empires fell.
- [Sal] Let's start in Achaemenid Persia.
So, Achaemenid Persia,
it's an empire that lasts
for roughly 200 years.
And I guess the obvious thing
about Achaemenid Persia,
it gets taken over by Alexander the Great.
So I'll just go ahead and
throw invasion on that list
for Achaemenid Persia.
So, outside of invasion,
if we go through the rest
of this list, it clearly
was a large empire,
so maybe there was an
element of over expansion.
It was governed in a fairly federated way
through these satraps.
You might have had bad
leadership be a role.
Darius III, famous for
deserting his troops
on the battlefield.
- [Steve] Yeah, and on top of that,
we might throw in economics as well,
because as Alexander conquers
bits and pieces of the empire,
he's also depriving them of the resources
that those areas would provide.
- [Sal] So, now let's
move on to Maurya India.
Once again, a significant empire,
lasts definitely over 100 years
and it's actually the
largest unified empire
over the Indian subcontinent.
And it starts with three
fairly strong rulers
and it's known, especially
with Ashoka the Great,
for spreading of the Buddhist religion.
So why, in your mind, Steve, did it fall?
Which of these factors
played most strongly?
- [Steve] Well, the
first one that jumps out
is over expansion.
Once Ashoka dies, you see
the empire really lose
a lot of that northwestern territory.
What we did see is some religious strife.
You mentioned that
Ashoka worked really hard
to spread Buddhism and he did follow that
in some of his policies
which led to some tension
between some of the Hindu
population in the empire.
- [Sal] And so you could also
call that division as well.
So, moving on.
Go to Han China.
It began to fall the end
of the second century CE
and then falls in the third century CE.
Which of these factors led
to its eventual demise?
- [Steve] Right.
So I think we want to start
looking at the fall of Han China
from the lens of the
Yellow Turban Rebellion.
And that is partly a religious movement
and it also is partly sparked
by environmental factors
leading to food shortages.
- [Sal] And food shortages
might affect the economy.
- [Steve] Absolutely.
And there's a lot of internal migration
to look for better jobs within
Han China because of this.
- [Sal] Do you think
leadership played a role?
- [Steve] Yeah.
There was a lot of dissatisfaction
with the Han emperor
and how he was sort of dealing
with some of these problems.
And over time, efforts
to defeat the rebellion
led to regional warlords
gaining more power
and then they eventually
carve out their own kingdoms
from the Han domain.
- [Sal] Okay.
And then, overlapping
in time with Han China,
we of course have the famous Roman Empire.
And on my timeline
here, this first section
is the Roman kingdom, then Roman republic,
and then you have the formal Roman empire
that collapses at the
end of the fifth century.
So which of these factors
do you think played...
In the Western Roman empire is collapsed,
the Byzantine empire, the
Eastern Roman empire continues on
for roughly a thousand years more.
- [Steve] Well, let's start
with the obvious point there
that there is a division.
There's a formal political division
that's gonna weaken both
halves of the empire
in terms of the resources available.
We also have, at the same
time as that division,
religious issues going on.
We have Christianity being
declared the official religion
of the Roman empire at this time
and that leads to internal conflicts
between those who are Christians
and those who are not.
- [Sal] You have migrations and invasions.
You have famously the Huns
migrating into Eastern Europe
and then putting pressure
on the Germanic tribes
to oftentimes come into the
Roman empire, but that led to...
So that was both migrations and invasion.
- [Steve] Yeah, and in this
case, it's sometimes hard
to separate invasion from migration.
- [Sal] And I would throw in economy
since the Roman empire, in
its expansionary period,
was constantly getting new territory
which would add tax
revenues to Rome's coffers.
It allowed for more and more
slaves who could work for Rome.
Once you get into the
third, fourth century CE,
that expansion starts to stop
and so it stops that
ever-growing pile of money
and ever-growing pile of labor.
So, I'd argue economy played a role.
You can never point to just one factor.
Empires are these very complicated things
but there are these general themes
and as a student, it's
valuable to think about them
in a framework something like this.
- [Steve] So all these factors won't apply
to every single empire you look at.
They're a good starting point
when you start thinking about
those questions of why did
this particular empire fall?
- [Sal] Awesome.
Thanks, Steve.
- [Steve] Thanks, Sal.